dc games are like buses you wait years
for one to come around and then a bunch
show up at once in 2022 alone we're
getting gotham knights and suicide squad
kill the justice league a dc fandom this
year we finally got more details on
gotham knights so here's everything you
need to know for all the latest on
gotham knights and suicide squad make
sure to like this video and subscribe
let's kick off with the plot and
confusingly gotham knights isn't
actually connected to rocksteady's
batman arkham games suicide squad kill
the justice league is but gotham knights
is an entirely original story set in a
different continuity it takes place
after batman's death yes you heard that
right death in the game's first trailer
batman sends a pre-recorded message to
his four proteges batgirl robin
nightwing and red hood to tell them that
he is gone the bat cave and everything
in it has been destroyed and that they
are gotham's only hope now interestingly
batman also calls out that they can't
count on the gotham city police
department anymore as they haven't
trusted the bat family since
commissioner gordon died we're not quite
sure how jim gordon died or even when he
died but given that his daughter barbara
is batgirl we're sure that'll come up
throughout the story of gotham knights
not wanting to leave the team completely
high and dry without any kind of hideout
or tech batman leaves them the belfry to
act as their base of operations in terms
of supporting roles for the young heroes
bruce wayne's butler alfred will help
out the team as well as renee montoya
the quote last honest cop a gcpd and
they'll need everything and every
everyone they can get their hands on
because the gotham criminal underworld
has quickly realized that batman's gone
there's obviously a huge rogues gallery
of baddies for the knights to take on
we've seen that mr freeze and penguin
are already trying to muscle in on
gotham but there's one particularly
formidable set of foes that will be the
main antagonists of the game the court
of owls a secret criminal society that
rules gotham from the shadows complete
with its own army of assassins called
the talons the court davaos is always
watching and listening and pulling the
strings from behind the scenes they
kidnap young kids and brainwash them
into becoming their assassins and have a
twisted way of dealing with their
enemies it's safe to say prepare
yourself for some mind-altering
hallucinations
and maybe a labyrinth the court of owls
are certainly a force to be reckoned
with and if you want to learn more about
them first of all check out scott snyder
and greg capullo's 2011 run in the
comics or take a look at this video our
very own tam made theorizing how they
could fit more into gotham knights i'll
link it in the description below fun
fact if you're wondering where the owl
part of the court comes from it's
because they're the natural predator of
the bat
each member of the team has their own
unique play style and abilities as well
as their own skill trees robin for
example can teleport by the justice
league satellite system and focuses more
on stealth nightwing has his acrobatics
red hood is proficient in many combat
techniques and batgirl will probably be
most familiar to those who have played
the arkham games having a similar
arsenal to batman as well as the tech
chops gotham knights can either be
played solo or with a friend via drop-in
dropout online co-op brawling will be
similar to the arkham games but the
combat system has been entirely
redesigned to work better in co-op so
you and a friend can do cool takedown
moves together
enemies will scale to your level so you
won't be prevented from going anywhere
or tackling something for fear of being
under leveled from the alpha gameplay
preview from 2020 where the gang tackles
mr freeze it was revealed that in these
villain encounters as they're called the
bosses will have different abilities
depending on the level you approach them
at if you decide to main one member of
the bat family you don't need to worry
about the others lagging behind as all
four share story progression and level
up even when you're not playing as them
it also looks like you can pick up items
from the bodies of foes but it's not
quite clear if there's crafting in the
game just yet but given that you have to
improve your equipment there might very
well be during the day the team will
regroup at the belfry working to find
clues improve equipment and prepare for
the night while you may not have the bat
cave and its tech treasures to help you
do have access to the bat computer which
according to wb montreal is an
incredibly important part of the game
when you're ready to venture out into
gotham to fight some crime the game will
fast forward you tonight gotham city has
five boroughs and they'll be bustling
with activity from villains like mr
freeze trying to manipulate the weather
to more run-of-the-mill crimes that the
bat family will need to tackle but at
the heart of the game will be the huge
mystery that you'll need to untangle the
court of owls gotham knights is being
made by wb games montreal who you might
recognize as the developers of batman
arkham origins from 2013. they also
worked on some of the dlc for arkham
knight in 2015. key death talent working
on the game includes its creative
director patrick redding who worked on
splinter cell blacklist and far cry 2
and its narrative director anne lemay
who worked on mass effect 3 and dragon
age inquisition originally set for 2021
gotham knights was delayed to some point
in 2022 it's set for release on
playstation 4 playstation 5 xbox one
xbox series s and x as well as pc
there you have it everything we know so
far about gotham knight for more on the
game as well as all the latest on
suicide squad kill the justice league
make sure to like this video and
subscribe i mentioned it earlier but tam
did a really great video about the cult
of owls and how they might fit into the
game some more so if you're looking into
some theory crafting i'll link it in the
description below i'm on twitter at lucy
james games and i'll catch you next time
i'll leave you with some gameplay from
gotham knights
this doesn't look up to code
hmm
[Music]
if anyone asks i meant to do that
i won't say a word
tours were still going on when freeze
came through
those poor people
they didn't stand a chance
gotham knights is built to let players
approach each challenge with their
preferred style and their preferred
build it is up
this will only take a second
[Music]
[Music]
no precisions
[Music]
[Music]
uh